oh
a half-term holiday nightmare it started
with panic on Bournemouth Beach on
Wednesday afternoon after 10 people got
into difficulty in the water and ended
with two children losing their lives
holiday makers watched on in horror it
was quite traumatic because also yeah
this whole area was fenced off and
obviously at the time I was upset
because I just know that I'm a mom
and that somebody wasn't going to get a
very good phone call so I was a bit
upset yesterday there was a real Hive of
activity from the lifeguards they were
out in the water they were on the beach
they looked
concerned I wouldn't say panicked they
were very professional
but it was quite clear something was
going on there were tons of sirens
coming in we'd been hearing them for a
while to be honest but there were tons
of them those in the water had tried to
help but to no avail the jet skis would
go around the pier looking for stuff
so me and three other Surfers offered to
help we actually huddled into the here
to have a look they said there were two
people missing at the time and then
after about half hour they said
uh everyone was accounted for a 12 year
old girl from buckinghamshire and a 17
year old boy from Southampton were taken
to hospital and later died the two
children weren't related and had been
visiting the area police have arrested a
man in his 40s on suspicion of
manslaughter who had been on the water
at the time
early investigation indicates that there
was no physical contact between a vessel
and any of the swimmers at the time of
the incident I can also confirm there is
no suggestion of people jumping from the
pier or jet skis being involved
officers are Keen to squash speculation
but the lack of answers fuels the
mystery how these Waters suddenly became
unsafe and deadly there were a number of
attempts yesterday to try and clear the
beach as chaos ensued onlookers praised
the efforts of response teams who
reacted within minutes
the leader of the council told me the
incident was extremely rare you can see
the beach is busy you know Bournemouth
is popular it is a safe place to come it
is a wonderful destination for people to
come down and enjoy you know the outside
and we will carry on doing everything we
can to make sure that the beach and the
Sea are as safe as they possibly can be
for everybody
for two families it is too late but
their loss is punctuated by so many
unknowns
in Bournemouth